hi everyone welcome to the daily
homeroom uh for those of you all who
aren't familiar with what this is or
might just be showing up off of facebook
or youtube uh this is khan academy's way
of making sure that we all stay
connected during school closures
obviously khan academy we're not for
profit mission free world class
education for anyone anywhere we could
have never predicted the situation that
we are all in now but over the last many
years we've been building resources in
math in science and humanities in
english and language arts for early
learners
that have been free and are free that
are not commercial they're supported by
philanthropic donations from folks like
yourself
and we've always intended them to be
used in conjunction with physical
classrooms so students could learn at
their own time and pace and master
concepts uh and also used by students
when they're outside of the classroom be
that tutor that their family could
otherwise not afford or if they don't
have access to certain types of classes
and it's translated into the languages
of the world so we could also imagine
there's parts of the planet that don't
have access to schooling or the types of
schooling that we would want for our own
children and that's where khan academy
we've also seen playing a role but when
the school closer started happening we
realized that it's our duty to step up
and to do more and so we want to provide
more supports for all of you students
teachers and parents we've been running
webinars for parents and teachers to try
to understand how do you navigate school
closures how do you do this somewhat ad
hoc homeschooling all of a sudden
on top of that we've been doing this
daily live stream which is really just a
place to talk about anything stay
connected it could be of topics of
interest and topics that you're
struggling with i encourage everyone
whether you're watching on facebook or
youtube or some we're always learning
about new ways people are watching this
put questions on the message board have
team members who are going to be
surfacing them to us and we're also
going to have i'm going to introduce
them in a second some experts on child
psychology especially for students with
special learning needs so definitely put
those questions as well but we'll answer
all and any questions i do want to make
a special shout out to all of you who've
helped support khan academy not only
over the years but especially over the
last few weeks
we are a non-profit
that is that runs through philanthropic
donation we were running at a deficit
even before this crisis had hit and as
you could imagine over the last few
weeks our server utilization is 2x 3x of
what it typically is so we need that
support even more now than than ever a
special thanks to bank of america at t
novartis and google.org for being some
of the first corporations to step up but
we need more we're still
running at a deficit so definitely get
those questions questions literally
about anything i like some of the fun
and frivolous ones as well and they can
also be serious ones about education or
about the coronavirus or whatever but
with that i'd like to introduce our two
guests for today we have laura phillips
who's a
a clinical uh psychologist a
neuropsychologist i should say at the
child mind institute and we also have
dave anderson who i believe is going to
be joining us as well
laura maybe a good place to start is
what are you seeing out there now that a
lot of you know we have this forced
social distancing what do you see as the
major issues that parents are coping
with students are coping with
sure so
parents have had to turn their homes
into their kids classrooms um and it's
it's
my patient population tends to be kids
who are struggling with learning
disorders or adhd and this is particular
it's challenging for all students now to
have to pivot and and shift their
learning to their home environment but
it's particularly challenging for kids
with learning disabilities who really do
need
explicit teacher directed recursive
learning approaches that just aren't
feasible right now through um
through remote learning so parents are
really having to step up in a way that
they've never needed to before and and
provide
the support that teachers are
traditionally providing their students
without any training
and it's a really big ask i say to all
the parents with whom i work it doesn't
matter how bright you are what a rock
star you are at your job how well you
know your student and your students
learning profile how well you parent
your individual student teaching them is
a very different thing um and a lot of
what teachers end up actually doing in
the classroom is really behavior
management um and and modifying the way
that they present information in a way
that makes it engaging and appealing to
their students and and parents now have
to be the ones doing that without uh the
the training and the experience that
their teachers do so so a lot of the
questions that i'm getting really is
about how do i keep my student engaged
how do i manage my students frustration
how do i how do i manage newly occurring
or pis or long-standing um oppositional
behaviors in the context of frustrating
academic situations
and so what are what are these
techniques what are some you know i've
experienced some of that in my own
household i think this for all students
not just special needs students but it
might some of this might be more
pronounced with those students what what
are some tangible things you would tell
parents who
maybe are having
trouble keeping their kids motivated or
engaged right now
well the first is to cut yourself some
slack and to cut your kids some slack
because this is really hard no one has
ever needed to do this with the
exception of parents who have opted to
homeschool their kids
before this occurred but but this is a
completely unprecedented and challenging
and stressful situation for kids and and
for parents who are having to manage uh
to balance the responsibilities of
working from home with raising their
kids and now with schooling them so the
first thing is really cut yourself some
slack this is not the time to strive for
perfection
and the most important thing really is
to maintain physical and mental health
right now
and after that communication with
teachers is really critical
a lot of the students with whom i work
have a lot of either environmental
modifications or
homework or school work modifications
that the teachers can really help
parents understand what level
of independence they should be expecting
of their students
how much time should they expect their
students to be able to work
independently on a task without uh
without a teacher a parent stepping in
and either monitor prompting or checking
in on them or some students might even
need a parent sitting next to them the
entire time to keep themselves on task
but the teacher is going to be the best
person to inform
what the child's capabilities are um
that's going to vary depending on the
child's age depending on the child's
learning profile
um
so again i would really turn to the
teachers and have the partner with the
teachers so that you really understand
what your role should be in supporting
your students
and
make to the extent that you can maintain
structure and consistency
um
you know which might mean starting the
day at the same time kids to be i think
waking up at the same time that they
historically wake up having good meals
um
at at standard times going to bed at the
same time setting your kids up for
success with respect to going sufficient
sleep eating well if your children are
prescribed medication making sure that
they continue to take their medication
as prescribed making sure that they have
um the tools that they need to complete
the the online work so whether that is a
computer or laptop knowing how to use
the the various online platforms that
schools are rolling out um
and schedules schedules i think are
really really critical for for students
with anxiety for students with adhd who
have a hard time not knowing what's
going to come next um and and
yeah you look like you're about to pop
into something how do you know you know
as you mentioned and i completely
understand you know sometimes you
mentioned parents might have to sit down
next to their student or uh they need to
understand from their teacher but what
we're seeing
in fact i think this is the majority
situation is parents are also having to
work right now and then
they're not getting a lot of information
in some cases from you know because
teachers are still trying to figure out
some districts are still figuring out
the virtualization plans
and
in some many cases the special needs
students they haven't even gotten that
far to think about that yet so what do
you tell those parents who
they they're they're trying to work
simultaneously but you know their
student might need someone to sit down
how do they navigate that
so shifts i think are really important
um partnering with your partner and and
trying to tag teams so that one person
can feel like they're getting work done
uh while supporting their students i
think that's that part of co-parenting
is really critical and i understand that
that's not feasible for a lot of people
but um that that's one thing that i
think can help parents feel as though
they're still keeping up with their work
although the reality is no one's going
to be as productive as they would be
under ideal circumstances and these
aren't ideal circumstances
um but again i would encourage parents
to really talk to teachers um and to
turn to to resources like you you
provide really nice um
uh i think uh complementary uh
educational programming that can that
can supplement a lot of what what
schools a role at schools
my i'm finding that schools really vary
in the amount of direction
um and and structure that they're
providing in their rollout of of
curriculum some schools have a very
strict schedule and they have online
class discussions throughout the day
other schools have just sent home
packets of information which can be
really overwhelming for students to sit
down
so when that's occurring i encourage
parents really to do a lot of chunking
for them
trying to break down these larger
packages
into smaller more manageable
chunks so that their kids don't feel uh
overwhelmed and then um avoid any of the
tasks um and alternating it with with
more appealing activities that they feel
like they have some sort of reward at
the end of engaging in something that's
really stressful and frustrating for
them and what do you say you know i'm
getting some questions over facebook one
from elizabeth henlon says any advice on
on probing with children who aren't
innately talkers but clearly dealing
with difficult pro difficulty processing
processing
i'm not sure that i understand that
question like like processing what's
going on in the world right now or you
know they're all of a sudden their
school has been closed how do they cope
with it
yeah they're not talking to their
friends as much they're you know their
parents are stressed they're watching
the news people are things are going on
yeah so kids don't kids do well when
they have information being in the dark
is stressful and anxiety-inducing for
anybody so i do encourage parents to
give kids information that they're
seeking in the developmentally
appropriate way um i think that one way
to manage that is is to really try to
help have kids lead the conversation by
asking questions that way you can answer
their questions um hopefully
satisfactorily without providing perhaps
more information than they're seeking
which which could inadvertently make
them more overwhelmed or anxious by the
by the situation um but but i think it's
important to shed light on the situation
um for kids um and also help them
understand that the things that you're
doing
are are
are intended to make them feel safe um
this is this is a problem that adults
are working on but there are concrete
things that that kids can do like
staying away from staying out of school
right now washing their hands frequently
um and following those rules as a way of
really helping to keep themselves safe
which makes them feel as though they
have some control over the situation
yeah and dave uh
do you have what's your sense of these
things too how would you tell i know we
talked about a couple of days ago how
would you think about coping with some
of these things and i have this other
question from someone who's talking
about uh
having trouble concentrating in studies
because of social anxiety
how does that play out in a
in this type of a situation um
dave what do you think about that
right i mean i think that you know if we
talk about anxiety for for one second
that's just that anxiety is often
brought on by new situations new things
that are unexpected things that you
haven't encountered before so kids who
have been socially anxious and even have
resolved it to some degree may find
themselves newly anxious in the midst of
a kind of new landscape where they're
wondering when they should jump in in
online classes or they're wondering how
public their comment might be or whether
or not others are chatting about them in
the background there could be a host of
new fears associated with that and in
reality the way that we help kids with
that is we help them to think about the
fact that whatever they might be afraid
of uh you know we try to restructure in
the moment that even what they're afraid
of the most may not be that terrible and
in reality you know the things they care
about may still be happening and we also
try to engage in exposure with them
where we say look it may be that you're
worried about how a comment might be
perceived but i need you to make two per
class and then let's go back to the
evidence and see you know how tough that
was or how anxious that made you and
over time we can get somebody from
perhaps being anxious to even
participate up to what their level of
participation might have been before
online education
yeah and more questions here
there's one student is talking about how
do they deal they have they're having
depression at the same time they have a
sat and a lot of studies to do how would
you
what advice would you give for them
either um i think i think laura and i
can both hit on different parts of this
question but i think it's it's something
where when we see kids who are preparing
for the sats what we're thinking about
i'll go back to a point that laura made
earlier which is just uh about chunking
it's that we know that somebody whose
mood might be low needs to not think
about the entirety of preparation for
the sat but rather you know think about
just what they're going to get done
today and then how they're going to
reward themselves with something that's
what we call behaviorally activated
which means we know that it's going to
improve their mood to some degree so we
try to plan out with teenagers do the
work first but in a manageable chunk and
likely a smaller chunk then pre-cove it
and then figure out how you're going to
do something for your mood and something
to feel connected you know afterwards
just to keep everything kind of in that
variety
yeah i would i would just add i mean
i don't know if this is pre-existing
depression but certainly social
isolation and and the the
uh lack of accessibility of things that
is that make us feel good is is lowers
our mood so another thing that i try to
encourage parents to do is the extent
that they can really try to mimic
um
their normal life um both with with
sticking to somewhat of a of a typical
routine
and finding ways even if you can't go
outside and and and have playdates with
with friends face to face trying to
encourage trying to schedule virtual
play dates um
making sure that you're scheduling time
for outdoor activity if you're in a
location where you're allowed to go
outside but certainly physical activity
we know has mood and mood boosting
effects um and and learning boosting
effects so i think uh certainly
scheduling in time for for physical
exercise and outdoor time um is really
critical both to support learning and
just and to support
mood
and again really trying to keep the day
is as close to a typical day as you can
i've had
i heard recently about a father who has
has a student with uh moderate
who's on the autism spectrum and and
drives
takes his son for a drive every morning
as though he were driving him to school
it's just a way to maintain some
semblance of of uh normalcy for him and
it really helps him to get into the
mindset of being in school so that may
not apply to the case of the student
with depression but really trying to
mimic things that that um that a typical
day uh
is helpful for students
and what what advice would you have we
have a quote i'll go ahead
oh i was just gonna say i will say one
other point for kids who are struggling
with social anxiety depression some of
the things that dr phillips and i are
talking about are not necessarily
intuitive and the great thing about at
least how organizations are adapting to
the coving crisis now is that
organizations like ours the child mind
institute and others have really moved
to a telehealth uh kind of forum where
not only are we working with active
patients but we'll also do brief
consultations on issues like this just
to ensure that families have support
during this time because you know this
is not intuitive how to deal with this
crisis in the context of kids who are
battling mental health disorders
and we have a question here from youtube
priscilla cruz is asking my child does
have adhd how much time is enough to
homeschool for a second grazer without
pushing them too far they're normally in
school for six hours and i think this is
a question that all parents are
struggling with is
normally school is six seven hours but
uh what is the minimum and what's maybe
the maximum for this type of a scenario
it's a it's a great question and again i
would i would encourage i think that the
teachers can be helpful in at least
advising what i mean if the teachers
haven't have concrete thing tasks for
students to complete um we certainly
want to it would be the goal for the
students to get through that work and
you might want to consult with teachers
about how long they would expect
students to either be engaged in that
work on a daily basis or how long they
would expect that packet
to take
for the student to complete
and beyond that
the the thing is especially with very
young students so and i'm considering
even a second grade student a very young
student so many things are are
educational even if they're not
traditionally found in a classroom so um
the
silver lining i mean there are i think a
lot of silver linings of this of this
crisis but there are other uh learning
opportunities that might um that
students might not otherwise have have
exposure to so
we have um students who are now doing
more chores around the house and they're
learning how to help their parents cook
and that's a that's a that's a
lesson you have there's math involved in
that there's chemistry involved in that
there's a lot of executive functioning
um developing with um with organization
and sequencing of steps and and patience
and perseverance and frustration
tolerance um so so there's learning
that's taking place even if it's not
traditional classroom type learning
um
boredom is actually i think a very
critical
experience for students to to have that
in our in our culture they don't have
many opportunities to feel and we know
that boredom really is how kids develop
and nurture their creativity so i think
you're going to see a lot of skills
coming out of this
crisis that might not have otherwise had
the opportunity to emerge and i think
that that's something that i really want
parents to to try to focus on to the
extent that they can um so even if
they're not engaged in traditionally
academic tasks there are other ways for
them to be
learning right now
all right and that's that's useful and
we have this the last question for today
on on this topic is from youtube catrin
situ myang as asking how can i manage
being a perfectionist what i'm studying
it makes me stressed because i always
say to myself i must get the best and do
the best how do you cope with that and
this is something adults
and children i think struggle with or
many do
i i'll start this one i think i think
one of the things that we talk about
perfectionism and uh young people or
students of any age right now
is that you know the landscape has truly
changed many colleges and high schools
uh are trying to adapt their grading
systems right now to
uh what's going on in online education
and may not be able to grade in exactly
the same way and of course for people
who already were concerned about grades
or wanted their their work to be perfect
that also means that the landscape for
their assessment is changing that can
lead to a lot of anxiety um you know one
of the things i think we're speaking
about a lot with families and with
educators right now is that as we all
adapt to this crisis it's good to kind
of capitalize on what we think is going
well or what quality work we think
others are producing and not to expect
perfect or the same level of work that
we would have seen prior to this because
people are just dealing with so many
more challenges so
again you know i think we'll go back to
an earlier point which is communicating
with your teachers about what's expected
on assignments is a good thing but for
many folks who opponent perfectionism
we're also trying to include the coping
thought that people are more empathic
right now they're more compassionate the
more willing to
possibly grade you positively because
they know that you may be dealing with
more than you would usually so it's not
something where every time it has to be
perfect you may actually have a little
bit more space going back to dr phillips
point about silver linings for
creativity
that's super useful and you know we've
gotten questions over even before this
crisis about things like procrastination
and you know one of the causes of
procrastination is a fear of realizing
that you maybe aren't able to do it as
much as you thought or might be harder
but
with kind of whether you call it
perfectionism or procrastination it's
really you know just get started
and and and you'll and then that motion
uh might help unblock some of the things
well laura dave thanks so much for
joining today uh this was super useful
uh i think a lot of people got got some
really interesting insights into this
thank you
thanks great thanks for having me
great so
so thanks everyone for joining today uh
you know i'll just give a reminder that
this is a a
a place for y'all to stay connected uh
in this time of social and distancing
you know send us requests send us
questions send us even folks that you
might want to see on this forum we'll
try to reach out to them i think a lot
of people are out there in the world
today trying to understand how they can
help how they can help you as parents
students and teachers i will remind
everyone again we are not for profit if
you're in a position please think about
donating to khan academy it's support
like that that allows us to support many
other folks uh one of the things that
you could expect to see over the next
couple of days and actually we've
already released it a little bit uh but
you're going to see a little bit more of
the next day or two is we release those
schedules for students of different age
groups uh
three weeks ago and we got a lot of
positive feedback from y'all that it was
useful to structure the day along the
lines that uh we were just hearing from
from our from our guest experts
what we've launching right now today
tomorrow are actually learning plans now
that it's becoming clearer that khan
academy is or that school is going to be
out of session uh probably through the
end of the school year
students are trying to figure out and
parents and teachers what could be done
not just over those two months but
potentially through the summer so that
you don't have five months of not just
only not learning but learning loss and
so expect to see some links for learning
plans on how you can space yourself out
especially in math if you're a sixth
grader seventh grader an algebra student
a third grader uh to make sure that you
are operating at grade level and beyond
as we go into the new school year and
and tomorrow and in the next few live
streams we'll go into a lot more depth
on that uh we just published a youtube
youtube video for those of y'all are on
youtube uh it's actually the latest
video that we just made public on our
youtube channel where if you look at
that it explains what these learning
plans look like and it has links in the
description to the various learning
plans and we're going to be posting it
on other social media shortly so with
that thank you so much for joining us
this is just a way for all of us to stay
connected and stay healthy and stay safe
you